The bottom line is Washington hates you. You might be wondering,
Steven, why are you talking about our government? I thought you'd covered scams.
That'd be my answer. I do covers games.
That's why we're talking about the COVID relief bill. Remember they told you,
Hey, when COVID hit, they said,
we're not going to leave you guys behind because we're massively incompetent.
You know, we're going to take care of you. We're going to pass stimulus,
checks money in your pocket. And you know what? Small businesses,
we're not going to let you fail. Right?
We got the PPP for you and look how well that turned out. Joel,
Olsteen's getting a $4.4 million kickback, but don't worry. He needs it.
He's a small up and coming pastor, Kanye, West little tiny shoe company.
He needs the PPP to stay alive.
It doesn't matter which side of the spectrum you're on. Listen,
Mitch McConnell called this a historic relief bill. What's historic about it.
Pete, you're getting 600 bucks. That's what they're giving you.
You know what Nancy Pelosi says about it.
She says it's a significant amount to America's working families.
They are a significant, a significant amount.
This lady is so out of touch. Listen, she got into politics in 1987, $600.
Wasn't even a significant amount back then,
but you're expected to take this lying down all the while that this thing is so
stuffed with pork, that the Baconator is jealous. Listen guys,
out of the $900 trillion that's being spent in this thing, Hey,
you're getting 18% of it. Where's the rest of the money go? Well,
a lot of it goes to the PPP program.
Remember we need Kanye West and Joel Olsteen to get more money where the other
part of this goes is detailed in a 5,000 page document that
nobody has read. Not me, not anybody in the house or the Senate,
but rest assured guys it's important. It's important stuff, guys,
like a $10 million for gender programs in Pakistan.
That's the kind of stuff that's getting passed in a COVID belt. And listen,
you can be a fan of gender programs in Pakistan,
but this has less to do with COVID than the furniture stimulus that was also
passed. Oh, that's right. You see these guys right here.
These two people who are supposedly on different sides of the aisle. Yeah.
They need new furniture, guys. You guys understand that, right?
They never let a good pandemic go to waste. Ladies and gentlemen,
they've a lot of themselves. Hmm. How much is that?
The $9 million for furniture for the cynic.
Are you joking?
I'm pretty sure you could buy an iron throne for each of the senators with that
kind of money and still have money leftover. These people hate you.
This is why I don't get political on my show, guys. I don't go left or right,
because if you bat for one side of the team, you can't criticize the game.
And the game is you get royally screwed and they get Royal Thrones to sit on
what their $89 million for furniture now among other things that is bill,
what else do we got here? What else guys? Well,
these geniuses in Washington have, uh,
officially made their policies on the succession and reincarnation of the Dalai
Lama clear, which thank God for that. We were all worried.
We all might die from pandemic.
If we didn't figure out the succession of the Dalai Lama it's pages long,
by the way, guys, the constitution, four pages long,
one stimulus check. That's a no brainer that should have been passed months ago.
Hey, 5,000 pages.
Oh, it's beyond.
To give you guys an idea of how much,
how far $900 billion could have gone.
Let's just say they gave this straight to the American people.
Let's say they go, Hey, the PPP, that was a massive mistake,
corruption everywhere. The money's going to the wrong people.
It's not going to the small businesses. Like they say, they are, you know,
you have people like a Atlantic diving supply,
still qualifying as small businesses with over a billion dollars in revenue.
That's a total joke. So they just gave it to the American people.
Instead of getting a $600 check,
every single person would be getting a $3,200 check. And listen,
if you've been out of work for the last, I don't know, nine months,
that's not even that much. That's not going to save your life.
Like Congress is acting like $600.
Is all of a sudden going to build a lifeboat and to give anything more would be,
you know, Oh my gosh, they don't need that. That's ridiculous. Dude.
People are so far behind $3,200 is a drop in the bucket and it's the
least you can do.
But instead of we're more worried about giving $130 million to Nepal
or $453 million to Ukraine. Listen,
I already saved Ukraine. Okay. My,
my designer can tell you that we're wasting money on things like a billion
dollars to the Smithsonian or $40 million to the Kennedy center,
$154 million to the national art gallery. And look,
I love art as much as the next guy,
but I'm pretty sure having access to the number one 1950 by Jackson.
Isn't the biggest priority on everyone's list.
Now all of this insanity has led up to maybe the most surprising thing of all,
uh, Donald Trump, making some sense on Twitter.
I am asking Congress to amend this bill and increase the ridiculously low
$600 to $2,000 or $4,000
for a couple.
I'm also asking Congress to immediately get rid of the wasteful and unnecessary
items from this legislation.
Now I know a lot of people are just going to say, Hey,
this is just political theater, which sure probably is. Uh,
but it doesn't make it any less true. You know, things can be true.
Even if they come out of the mouth of a guy that you like, you dislike,
it doesn't make the statement any less true.
Congress needs to get rid of these ridiculous amendments to this.
What should be a straightforward bill? You know,
get relief into the hands of the American people that you forced to shut down
their businesses. You know, the government forced to shut down their shops.
So we could all chip in for each other for this pandemic. But all of a sudden,
when it comes down to giving you money,
you're left holding the bill and instead Sudan and Burma end up with all the
money. While these two are left, trying to fist,
I guess these people are an embarrassment. Anyways.
I just wanted to cover that because it's just a historic level of
scam artistry going on at the highest levels of government. Meanwhile,
you're getting shafted and I wanted to document and guys, cause this is Janell.
We cover scams. That's what we do. And this bill, this COVID relief bill.
It's a scam it's COVID relief in name only. Thanks for watching.
See you guys next time.
[Inaudible].